وصفت شبكه سي ان ان تسريحه ترامب هذا بانه
اكثر الاشياء ترامبيه التي قالها الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب حتى الان فيما قالت
الصحيفه بصحيفه نيويورك تايمز او الصحفيه
في نيويورك كان زمان
التي الفت كتابا عن ترامب انه غاضب للغايه
بعد خساره محمد اوزلي مقعد السنهور في بن
سلفانيا تضيف انه القاب باللون على من على
زوجته ترامب التي نصحتهم بالدعم به خلال
الانتخابات بدعم محمد اوز وانه ابلغ
مقربين بانها هذه هي اسوا نصيحه ازدتها له
زوجته حسب استطلاعات هجريت قبل الانتخابات
حصل ايه ترامب على نسبه قبول من الناخبين
بلغت 39% فيما حصل على قبولا متدنه ايضا
ولكن ب 41% لم تكن بصمات ترامب حاسمه
لصالح الجمهوريين في هذه الانتخابات حيث
ايد المرشحين الجمهوريين لمنصب حاكم
الولايه في بنسلفانيا ماريلاند الينوي
ميشيغن كلها هؤلاء
خسيروا لكن في مجلس الشيوخ كان الوضع نوعا
ما افضل قليلا حيث فاز المرشحون الذين
دعمهم في نورث كارولينا وهايو ايضا في
نيفادا يتقدم ادم همم لك لاكس اوت همم
الذي ان يدعمه ترامب على السيناتور
الحاليه الديمقراطيه طبعا
فيما يحتدم السباق في جورجيا بين المرشح
الذي يدعمه همم هيرشال ووكر
الديمقراطيه همم
سيذهب الاثنين الى جوله كما ذكرنا سابقا
ينفع